SE who wants to see a
fight who wants to see a
[Applause]
fight had a great event today with Kam
Chay and the guys here in Birmingham I
just want to say that before you watch
this video you're going to have a good
time watching it trust me before you
watch this video click the link below
and donate to Prov Palestine these guys
313 have been fully vetted they're on
the ground 100% they're doing great work
we need you to donate it's going to be
amazing watch the
video The Hitman hijab let me hear it
from
him The
Undefeated Undisputed world two King
Champion you can't handle this guy when
onair Morgan and bat him
up right straight
standard I bow humbly to this
brother right I bow humbly to this
brother ham that
J may this guy is 13
and0 this man is so tough that he could
kill
concrete
now who do you think is going to win let
me hear
it
now um I'm I'm with my
brother hijab you know why I'm with him
because it's not a wrestling competition
it's going to be a talking competition
no right we've got what 2 minutes 2
minutes 2 minutes we got 2 minutes okay
I have to back of my coat for this one
bro pulling to the center of the Octagon
the two fighters face Face Off Face Off
everybody fight fight fight fight
fight fight fight fight
fight seconds
out SE who wants to see a
fight who wants to see a
fight ladies and
Gentlemen let's get ready to
rumble
[Applause]
oh ooh take down take down take down
take down
oh alhamdulillah let me hear it from our
brother Mr hijab and ham
T put both your hands up together
pleas the two winners mashah